I wonder why so many Millennials have
anxiety and then it's like Millennials
childhood movies and it's this list of
just these Horrors that we watch that
were branded as kids movies for me home
alone came out when I was a kid sure
that was supposed to be like a kids
movie but do you remember the furnace
scene yeah okay that me up also
Brave Little
Toaster what the man where your
things actually are alive and have
feelings and like can murder one another
when the when the AC unit goes out in
Brave Little Toaster sounds tough
anyways haven't been in the ocean since
I saw Jaws next that wasn't like a kids
movie that was a horror movie back then
there weren't kids movies no one said
like hey this is a kids movie they were
like Hey we're watching something as a
family I know I've smoked a pack of
cigarettes in here with all the doors
shut get the fck in here and you get
your lung cancer and you watch this
godamn shark eat people